we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p here is a caller who is very
angry at first I thought they were angry
with me but they generally seem angry
overall take a listen yeah book your eye
right now when you're bought and paid
for just like all the other [ __ ] bunch
of books yeah the wife don't stop nobody
gives a rat's ass about nobody on this
planet especially this ash cloud asian
orgy Hitler agent orange Hitler as a
reference to trump is funny I thought
that this was somebody who hated me it
seems that they just hate everybody
maybe he's just hating everyone that
yeah that's what it the cherry on top on
these phones with these voicemails is
when you hear the show playing in the
background and it's not getting paused
for the person to call in something
about that does amps up the funny for me
when when the show is playing in the
background we've got a great bonus show
for you today I don't even want to tell
you what's on it but I kind of will a
little bit i'm going to talk about the
scam of the diamond industry something
i've talked about before i'm going to
talk about people looking for roommates
along political lines not wanting trump
supporters living in their homes and
much much more you can get instant
access to the bonus show by signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership we
do have a coupon code available it is i
voted 17 if the normal membership rates
are high for you use the coupon code I
don't mind and you will get instant
access to the bonus show which starts in
mere minutes